This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. It was a cold day in Appalachia on January 7th, 1865. A Union soldier named Esa McCoy was on his way home, wounded from fighting in the Civil War. As he neared his cabin in Kentucky, Esa was given a message, Don't return home or you will be killed. A local group of Confederate militia, known as the Logan Wildcats, planned to kill Asa. The Wildcats were led by a member of the Hatfields, a family living in West Virginia who had strong ties to the Confederate army. Asa hid out in a cave near Peter Creek, Kentucky. But it
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。那是1865年1月7日，阿巴拉契亚地区迎来了寒冷的一天。一名叫埃萨·麦科伊的联邦士兵在内战中负伤后正在回家的路上。当他靠近肯塔基州的简陋小屋时，有人传话给埃萨，叫他不要回家，否则会被杀害。当地的一个邦联民兵组织，被称为洛根野猫队，计划杀死阿萨。野猫队由黑特菲尔德家族的一员领导，这个家族住在西弗吉尼亚州，与邦联军队有着紧密的联系。阿萨藏在肯塔基州彼得克里克附近的一个山洞里。但他
was no use. He was eventually tracked down and shot dead. The incident is said to have sparked a famous feud between the Hatfields and the McCoys. It lasted decades. In 1873, a McCoy family member, perhaps still seething from Asa's death, accused Floyd Hatfield of stealing his pig.a's death, accused Floyd Hatfield of stealing his pig. A trial followed and Floyd Hatfield was acquitted. A few years later, one of the
无济于事。他最终还是被追踪到并被枪杀。据说这起事件引发了黑特菲尔德家族与麦科伊家族之间著名的世仇。这场世仇持续了几十年。1873年，也许仍对阿萨的死感到愤怒，一名麦科伊家族的成员指控弗洛伊德·黑特菲尔德偷了他的猪。随後进行了一场审判，弗洛伊德·黑特菲尔德被判无罪。几年后，其中一位
trial witnesses was killed by two McCoys. In 1882, on election day in Kentucky, some McCoy brothers drunkenly fought and killed Ellison Hatfield, stabbing him multiple times in the back. In retaliation, the Hatfields killed all three McCoy brothers. The feud continued into a cycle of violence that reached its peak in 1888, during what came to be known as the New Year's Night Massacre. Several members of the Hatfield gang set fire to a McCoy cabin and killed two children. History is full of incidents that have sparked long-standing grudges, sometimes with consequences
审判证人被两名麦科伊家族成员杀害。1882年，在肯塔基州的选举日，几个麦科伊兄弟喝醉后与埃利森·黑特菲尔德发生冲突并将其杀害，他的背部被多次刺中。作为报复，黑特菲尔德家族杀害了所有三个麦科伊兄弟。这场世仇演变成了一轮又一轮的暴力冲突，并在1888年达到顶峰，那场事件后来被称为新年之夜大屠杀。黑特菲尔德帮的几名成员放火烧了一间麦科伊家族的小屋，并杀害了两个孩子。历史上充满了引发长期积怨的事件，有时其后果
that last decades. But there also are smaller, more personal grievances that we all harbor. Perhaps you still remember some slight you experienced years ago at the hands of a friend or family member? Today we explore the psychology of grudges, how long-standing animosities affect our lives, and what to do about them. This week on Hidden Brain. Don't let people live rent-free in your head. That's a way of saying you shouldn't allow people who have wronged you to take up too much of your attention.
会持续几十年。但我们每个人心中也怀有一些更小、更私人的怨恨。也许你还记得多年前朋友或家人对你的某种轻慢？今天我们将探讨怨恨的心理学，长期的敌意如何影响我们的生活，以及该如何应对。本周的《隐藏的大脑》。别让人们免费住在你的脑子里。这是一种说法，意思是你不应该让那些伤害过你的人占用你太多的注意力。
Sounds nice, but is it realistic? We are social creatures after all, and our interactions and relationships with others matter. When someone is kind to us, it has the power to alter our day, maybe even change the course of our lives. When someone wrongs us, it can also have large effects. At Stanford University, Fred Luskin has spent a quarter century studying what happens when we hold on to grudges. Fred Luskin, welcome to Hidden Brain. Hey, thank you so much.
听起来很美好，但这现实吗？毕竟我们是社会性动物，我们与他人的互动和关系至关重要。当别人对我们友善时，它有力量改变我们的一天，甚至改变我们的人生轨迹。当别人伤害我们时，也会产生巨大的影响。在斯坦福大学，弗雷德·卢斯金花费了四分之一世纪的时间来研究当我们心怀怨恨时会发生什么。弗雷德·卢斯金，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。嘿，非常感谢。
Fred, some years ago you met a woman named Debbie. She was having issues with her husband. And when I say issues, this was not merely conflicts about who takes out the garbage. No. I mean, issues, that's a nice way of putting it. Her husband was a serial adulterer. She had found him cheating numerous times. He said, I'm sorry.
弗雷德，几年前你遇到了一位名叫黛比的女士。她和丈夫之间出现了一些问题。当我说问题时，这不仅仅是关于谁来倒垃圾的冲突。不。我的意思是，问题，这是一种委婉的说法。她的丈夫是个惯犯。她曾多次发现他出轨。他说，我很抱歉。
She said, okay, I'll take you back. He did it again. The cycle repeated itself over and over. One day, Debbie came home early from work. She discovered her husband on the couch with another woman. It was the last straw. Something snapped in her. She said, no more, you'll never treat me like this again.
她说，好吧，我接受你回头。他又犯了。这个循环周而复始。有一天，黛比下班回家早了。她发现丈夫和另一个女人在沙发上。这是最后一根稻草。她心里有什么东西崩塌了。她说，够了，你再也别想这样对我了。
She threw him out. She filed for divorce. But when we met her, this guy owned her brain, and her conversation was just so dominated by him, him, him, him, him. So many people have been in similar situations where they have been betrayed by a romantic partner and people really struggle with it. How was Debbie's account of what happened to her affecting her life, Fred?
她把他赶了出去。她提出了离婚。但当我们遇到她时，这家伙占据了她的脑海，她的谈话完全被他、他、他、他、他所支配。有很多人都曾处于类似的情况中，被浪漫伴侣背叛，人们对此真的很难释怀。黛比对她所经历的事情的讲述是如何影响她的生活的，弗雷德？
Oh, there's a sadness or a poignancy sometimes when you see people who are hurt like that. Her conversation is about my ex and the lost marriage and what a bad person he was, but it shrouded in failure. It's, this didn't work, I couldn't make it happen. I did my best, there were obstacles too big for me. And that has implications for her entire life. I understand that it was important for her to let everyone else know what
哦，当你看到那些受伤害的人时，有时会有一种悲伤或辛酸。她的谈话内容总是围绕着我的前夫、失败的婚姻以及他是一个多么糟糕的人，但它笼罩在失败的阴影中。它是，这行不通，我无法挽回。我尽力了，但有我无法逾越的障碍。这对她整个人生都有影响。我理解对她来说，让所有人知道她的丈夫是
allows her husband was and how much pain he had caused her. That that is true for her. It's like, let me tell you now, let me tell you now, let me tell you again. Now, let me call up grandma and tell her. The real suffering is when that failure and that loss become part of their identity. And so for somebody like Debbie, when we had encountered her, it was, hi, I'm Debbie, a woman with a lousy ex-husband and a failed marriage. So that had meant that it was now integrated into her self-concept. In the course of your work and research, you came by another person named Jill, and she
什么样的人以及他带给她多少痛苦是很重要的。对她来说确实如此。这就好像是，让我现在告诉你，让我现在告诉你，让我再告诉你一遍。现在，让我打电话给奶奶告诉她。真正的痛苦在于，那种失败和失落变成了他们自我认同的一部分。因此，对于像黛比这样的人，当我们遇到她时，情况就是：嗨，我是黛比，一个有着糟糕前夫和失败婚姻的女人。这意味着这已经融入了她的自我概念中。在你的工作和研究过程中，你遇到了另一个人叫吉尔，她
confided in you about her troubled relationship with her mother. But unlike in the case of Debbie's ex, Jill's mother was dead? So she was, my mom didn't love me. I never got the kind of affection that I would hope for. I felt rejected and unwanted, and I grew up with this sense of not being good enough and not having enough value in this world. And no matter what I said to mom, I couldn't get through to her.
向你吐露了她与母亲之间糟糕的关系。但与黛比的前夫的情况不同，吉尔的母亲已经去世了？所以她是，我妈妈不爱我。我从未得到我所期望的那种关爱。我感到被拒绝和不受欢迎，我在这种觉得自己不够好、在这个世界上没有足够价值的感觉中长大。无论我对妈妈说什么，我都无法与她沟通。
Like, mom, notice me, mom, I'm around. Notice, I'm mad at her. Mom was impenetrable. And so Jill brought that sense of frustration and invisibleness to the way she talked about what it was that had occurred 20 years ago when her mother had died. You could just feel the angst. You know, what is striking about both these stories you've just told me, Fred, is that
就像，妈妈，注意到我，妈妈，我在旁边。注意，我在生她的气。妈妈是刀枪不入的。因此，当吉尔谈到20年前她母亲去世时发生的事情时，她把那种挫败感和隐形感带入了谈话中。你简直能感受到那种焦虑。你知道，弗雷德，你刚刚讲述的这两个故事最引人注目的是，
in both Debbie's case and in Jill's case, the source of their pain is in their past, but it's almost as if this person, this other person, is standing with them, walking with them, living with them inside their heads all the time. Precisely. And what you articulated is one of the unanticipated consequences of keeping a grievance alive. And they don't realize how integrated that wound or problem has become in their self-identity. And that link, that integration, makes it seem really hard to imagine what would I be without this.
无论是在黛比的案例中还是在吉尔的案例中，她们痛苦的根源都在于过去，但几乎就像这个人，另一个人，一直和她们站在一起，和她们一起走，和她们一起活在她们的脑海里。确实如此。而你所阐述的正是保持怨恨所带来的未曾预料的后果之一。她们没有意识到那个创伤或问题已经多么深地融入到她们的自我认同中。而这种联系、这种融合，让人很难想象如果没有了这个，自己会是什么样。
So you're a scholar, you're a teacher, you're a therapist, but you're also a human being, and you yourself are not invulnerable to holding on to a grievance. I want you to tell me the story of your friend Sam, and what happened to you and Sam, and maybe you to tell me the story of your friend Sam and what happened to you and Sam, and maybe start with how close you were to Sam for many years of your life. Sam was my closest friend for probably a decade. Somebody I considered almost a brother and a very, very dear friend of my wife and I. I assumed that Sam would always hold that place in my life. So what happened or what transpired was he met someone
所以你是一位学者、一位老师、一位治疗师，但你也是一个人，你自己也并非刀枪不入，无法免于心怀怨恨。我想让你给我讲讲你朋友萨姆的故事，你和萨姆之间发生了什么，也许你可以讲讲你和朋友萨姆的故事以及你们之间发生了什么，或许可以从你生命中多年来与萨姆有多亲密开始讲起。萨姆是我大约十年来最亲密的朋友。我把他看作几乎是兄弟，也是我和我妻子非常非常亲爱Một的朋友。我曾以为萨姆永远会在我的生活中占据那个位置。那么发生了什么或者说发生了什么转变是，他遇到了一个人，
who was for whatever reason, uncomfortable with the relationship that Sam had with me and my wife. This is a romantic partner? Yeah. And he just disappeared. We're best friends and now, poof. And I couldn't connect with him and the word ghosted did not exist then, but I was ghosted. And inside of me, I fell apart.
无论出于什么原因，这个人对萨姆与我和我妻子保持的关系感到不舒服。这是一个浪漫伴侣吗？对。然后他就消失了。我们是最好的朋友，而现在，砰地一下，没了。我无法与他联系，当时还没有“被断联”（ghosted）这个词，但我被断联了。在我的内心深处，我崩溃了。
I became bitter as my trust was shattered and I developed a bit of like an agitated depression. I understand that at one point Fred you heard that Sam was to be married and you did not hear about this from Sam but from someone else. When a mutual friend came to my house and said, Oh, by the way, you know, he's getting married. I had absolutely no ability to integrate that information. It hit me like bricks in my face. And I just I crumbled. So you were not invited to the wedding.
我的信任破裂，我变得痛苦，并且患上了一种激越性抑郁症。我听说弗雷德你在某个时候听说萨姆要结婚了，而你不是从萨姆那里听到这个消息的，而是从别人那里听到的。当一个共同的朋友来到我家说，哦，顺便说一句，你知道，他要结婚了。我完全没有能力消化这个信息。它就像砖头一样迎面砸在我的脸上。我整个人崩溃了。所以你没有被邀请参加婚礼。
This is someone whom you consider to be, as you said, your best friend, nearly a brother. How did that change your outlook and behavior? I understand that the people around you started to notice that you were different. My wife turned to me one day and said, Fred, I still love you. I just don't like you as much.
这是一个你认为的，正如你所说，你最好的朋友，亲如兄弟的人。这如何改变了你的观点和行为？我听说你身边的人开始注意到你变了。我妻子有一天转向我说，弗雷德，我依然爱你。我只是不像以前那么喜欢你了。
Wow. So I was, to put it kindly, crabby. I understand that at one point during the saga, Fred, you found yourself in a very unusual place to have an epiphany, the supermarket. Tell me what happened at the supermarket that day. So my wife told me to go to the supermarket. And I told her I wanted to go to supermarket A because it was closer. She said, go to supermarket B, Safeway.
哇。所以，委婉地说，我很乖戾。我听说在这场风波的某个时刻，弗雷德，你发现自己处在一个非常不寻常的地方，从而有了顿悟，那就是超市。告诉我那天在超市发生了什么。所以我的妻子让我去超市。我告诉她我想去A超市，因为它更近。她说，去B超市，Safeway。
It has what I want. I walked out of the door muttering, poor me. I get to Safeway muttering all the time, you know, people don't understand me and all the, really, like, bitter. I walk to the place with the item that my wife is going to send me to Safeway for, and it's not there. And my self-pity is overwhelming. I could have gone to Albertsons and why am I here? And nobody loves me and my self-pity went to a kind of overdrive
那里有我想要的东西。我嘟囔着“我真命苦”走出了家门。我一路上都在Safeway嘟囔着，你知道，人们不理解我之类的话，真的，非常痛苦。我走到妻子让我去Safeway买的那样东西的货架前，结果没有。我的自怜情绪达到了顶点。我本可以去Albertsons的，我为什么会在这里？没有人爱我，我的自怜情绪进入了一种超速运转的状态。
But if there was a moment Where it broke just one moment I turned away from the Shelf where the item was supposed to be and I noticed for the first time I'm in Safeway big supermarket But I literally said to myself, holy sh** Fred, look what you're missing. You're missing abundance. This store has everything. You're missing apples and oranges and diapers and that you have the money to pay for this. So I had a voice almost in me that said, pay attention Fred, pay attention.
但如果说有那么一个时刻一切崩溃了，就那么一个瞬间，我转过身，背对着本该有那件商品的货架，我生平第一次注意到，我在Safeway，一家大超市，但我 literalmente 对自己说，天哪，弗雷德，看看你错过了什么。你错过了丰盛。这家店应有尽有。你错过了苹果、橙子和尿布，而且你有钱支付这一切。所以我内心几乎有个声音在说，注意听，弗雷德，注意听。
I walked out of that supermarket and I was different. For better and worse, people we are close to can affect us in profound ways. Sometimes these effects are fleeting, and sometimes they last for years. When we come back, the physiological and psychological effects of holding a grudge. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. When someone wrongs us, holding a grudge against them almost feels like a form of justice. But psychologist Fred Luskin says that more often than not, grudges don't hurt the targets of our anger. They hurt us. Fred, we've discussed a few ways in which people can hurt us, but sometimes it's a process that hurts us. One person you worked with was upset she did not get a job promotion.
我走出了那家超市，我整个人都变了。无论好坏，我们亲近的人都会对我们产生深远的影响。有时这些影响转瞬即逝，有时则会持续多年。稍后回来，我们将探讨心怀怨恨对生理和心理的影响。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。当别人伤害我们时，对他们心怀怨恨几乎感觉像是一种正义的形式。但心理学家弗雷德·卢斯金表示，更多时候，怨恨并不会伤害我们愤怒的对象。它们伤害的是我们。弗雷德，我们已经讨论了几种人们伤害我们的方式，但有时这个过程本身就在伤害我们。你合作过的一个人因为没有得到升职而感到沮丧。
Can you tell me Dana's story and what went through her mind? a job promotion. Can you tell me Dana's story and what went through her mind? Dana is one of the people that even after a decade or more, I still remember. Her issue was that she was a great worker for a local Silicon Valley company who worked above and beyond what anybody could expect from an employee. She came in early. She also was ambitious. And so she had an expectation that that best effort would lead to a promotion. So after a number of years of getting promoted appropriately, there was a bigger job right ahead of her that she just knew she was the right person for the job and had earned it.
你能讲讲达娜的故事以及她脑海里在想什么吗？晋升工作。你能讲讲达娜的故事以及她脑海里在想什么吗？达娜是那些即使在十年或更久之后，我依然记得的人之一。她的问题在于，她是当地一家硅谷公司的优秀员工，她的工作超越了任何人对员工的期望。她上班很早。她也很有野心。因此，她期望这种最大的努力能带来晋升。所以在经过多年合理的晋升之后，她面前有一个更大的职位，她清楚地知道自己就是这个职位的合适人选，并且已经赢得了它。
And when she found out that she didn't get that job, she became furious. I mean, hell hath no fury. I mean, because she had checked all the boxes. So if I understand correctly, Fred, Dana's reaction to not being promoted was the sense that she had wasted 10 years of her life, that all this time and effort she had spent at the company going above and beyond, all of it was wasted effort. Wasted effort and that she was an idiot for putting in all that effort. It was a multi-pronged attack towards both her employer and towards herself. Let's look
当她发现自己没有得到那个职位时，她愤怒极了。我的意思是，怒火中烧。因为她已经符合了所有的条件。所以如果我理解正确的话，弗雷德，达娜对未能晋升的反应是觉得她浪费了生命的10年，她花在公司里超越期望的所有时间和精力，全都是白费力气。白费力气，而且她觉得自己付出那么多努力是个笨蛋。这是一场针对她的雇主和她自己的多方位攻击。让我们来看看
at one aspect of the story you just told me. So this was an employee who did not get a promotion. Another way of looking at this is to say the company has a number of different priorities. Maybe I don't fully understand all the priorities of the company. They've picked somebody else, but it's actually not about me. It's just about what the company needed to do at this time. Exactly. The not getting the promotion. Dana heard that, that it's about Dana.
你刚才讲的故事的一个方面。所以这是一位没有得到晋升的员工。看待这件事的另一种方式是说公司有许多不同的优先事项。也许我并不完全理解公司的所有优先事项。他们选择了别人，但这其实与我无关。这只是公司在这个时候需要做的事情。正是如此。未能晋升。达娜听到的却是，这与达娜有关。
She took it personally. It's my company, my job. I did all this work. I made all this effort. She took the no, the rejection as a personal affront. Now in some ways it's worth pointing out of course that not getting that promotion did indeed have personal effects on Dana. It might have affected her life, her finances, maybe even her retirement plan. So it had consequences in her personal life, Fred. Absolutely. So there's no denying that Dana's body and mind were affected by not getting the job. What there is room to negotiate is how much of that effect had to do with Dana's expectations,
她把它当成了个人问题。这是我的公司，我的工作。我做了所有这些工作。我付出了所有这些努力。她把“不”、把拒绝当作是对自己个人的侮辱。现在从某些方面来看，值得指出的是，未能获得晋升确实对达娜产生了个人影响。它可能影响了她的生活、她的财务状况，甚至她的退休计划。所以它对她的个人生活产生了后果，弗雷德。绝对是的。所以不可否认的是，未能得到这份工作影响了达娜的身体和心灵。有协商空间的是，这种影响中有多大程度与达娜的期望有关，
not just the not getting the job. I want to talk about another component of grudges, Fred. You walked with a man named Alan, whose wife cheated on him. Can you tell me his story and the thoughts that constantly circled around in his mind? So, Alan had a wife who cheated on him, like, and she didn't, like, try to hide it. You know, it was like, we're married,
而不仅仅是因为没有得到这份工作。我想谈谈怨恨的另一个组成部分，弗雷德。你曾陪伴过一个名叫艾伦的男人，他的妻子背叛了他。你能讲讲他的故事以及他脑海中不断盘旋的想法吗？所以，艾伦有一个出轨的妻子，而且她甚至不试图隐瞒。你知道，就像是，我们结婚了，
but you don't satisfy me, so, you know, I have an affair. And she shut him down if he started to complain But you don't satisfy me. So, you know, I have an affair and She shut him down if he started to complain or articulate his needs So Alan just had one of those like doozies of a story. It's all her fault the blame is the second piece of a three-part sequence. It starts with taking it too personally, which you covered. When we take things too personally, our mind and body react in a very harsh
但你无法满足我，所以，你知道，我有外遇。如果他开始抱怨，她就会让他闭嘴。但你无法满足我，所以，你知道，我有外遇。如果他开始抱怨或表达他的需求，她就会让他闭嘴。所以艾伦就有着这样一个奇葩的故事。这全是她的错，责备是三部曲序列中的第二部分。它始于过度个人化，你已经涵盖了这一点。当我们把事情看得太个人化时，我们的身心就会以一种非常严厉、
physically disruptive and emotionally suffering way and Then we have to talk to ourselves about what happened So all three of those end up as this quality of blame You you did it to me. I'm not responsible for how bad I feel, and I'm going to talk to myself that solidifies this as a blaming story. I can see in some ways how, at least on a short-term basis, this can make you feel better. If you're feeling very upset, if you're feeling very hurt, it does make you feel better to say, I know what the cause of my hurt is.
对身体具有破坏性且在情感上痛苦的方式做出反应，然后我们必须对自己讲述发生了什么。所以这三者最终都体现为一种责备的品质。你对我做了这个。我对自己的糟糕感觉不负责任，我要对自己说这样的话，从而将这巩固为一个责备的故事。在某种程度上，我可以看到至少在短期内，这能让你感觉好一些。如果你感到非常沮丧，如果你感到非常受伤，说“我知道我受伤的原因是什么”，确实能让你感觉好一些。
It's this other person. This other person did this terrible thing and that's why I'm feeling terrible. It's her fault. You're spot on with that because when people are devastated, it's appropriate to be disrupted, dysregulated, confused, angry, lost, scared and short term, it's really helpful to have somebody to blame besides you. So we've talked about the role that taking things personally and the blame game plays in the development of a grudge. These often lead to what you call the final stage in the grievance process, the construction of a grievance story. What do you mean by this, Fred? When something happens, we have a choice of how we talk about it.
是这个其他人。这个其他人做了这件可怕的事，这就是我感觉糟糕的原因。这都是她的错。你完全说对了，因为当人们遭受毁灭性打击时，感到受到干扰、失调、困惑、愤怒、迷失、害怕是合情合理的，而在短期内，除了你自己之外，能有一个责备的对象真的很有帮助。所以我们已经讨论了将事情个人化和责备游戏在怨恨发展中所起的作用。这些通常会导致你所说的怨恨过程的最后阶段，即怨恨故事的构建。弗雷德，你这是什么意思？当事情发生时，我们对于如何谈论它是有选择的。
And so we can talk about it as a normal life event, a catastrophe, something to cope with, you know, something I'm here to learn from, or a sign that the world is an unfair, unsafe place. What we lose when we get too deep into a grievance story is one, we have a choice. So that story of, hey, I got a really crappy deal with this wife and she messed up my life for six months, that's a healthy story for a month or so. You know, it's like that's how your brain rebalances and reorganizes itself from the disruption and it can go directly to, oh, let's think about this. I didn't make a good choice in marriage.
因此我们可以把它谈作一个正常的生活事件、一场灾难、一件需要应对的事情，你知道，一件我要从中学习的事，或者是一个世界是一个不公平、不安全地方的信号。当我们陷入怨恨故事太深时，我们失去的一点是，我们是有选择的。所以那个故事，嘿，我从这个妻子那里得到了一个非常糟糕的待遇，她把我的生活搞砸了六个月，这对于一个月左右的时间来说是一个健康的叙事。你知道，这就像是你的大脑如何从混乱中重新平衡和重组自身，并且它可以直接过渡到，哦，让我们想想这个。我在婚姻中没有做出好的选择。
She gave me lots of clues. I didn't do X. You can't reorganize coherently right away, so she's a terrible human being is a wonderful way to reorganize. The Grieving Story is a practice for how it is we're going to explain to ourselves what happened and what's an appropriate response for us to deal with it. and what's an appropriate response for us to deal with it. The practice of it is very useful short term and destructive long term. I'm curious why some wrongdoings become grudges and others don't.
她给了我很多线索。我没有做X。你无法立刻连贯地进行重组，所以“她是一个可怕的人”是重新重组的一个绝佳方式。怨恨的故事是一种练习，练习我们如何向自己解释发生了什么，以及对我们来说什么是应对它的恰当反应。而对我们来说什么是应对它的恰当反应。这种练习在短期内非常有用，但长期来看极具破坏性。我很奇怪为什么有些错事会变成怨恨，而另一些则不会。
You talk about a very powerful concept, the violation of unenforceable rules. What does this mean, Fred? When Dana wanted a promotion, she turned what she wanted into an expectation. I want to be promoted, she turned it into I have to be promoted. When somebody gets married they have a hope, you know, I want my partner to be faithful, but they change it into they have to be faithful. That is a rule for somebody else's behavior that you actually don't have power to enforce. If you wake up in the morning and you say, hey, I got a big day today, it has to be sunny, and it's pouring, most normal people recognize
你谈到了一个非常强有力的概念，即违背不可执行的规则。弗雷德，这是什么意思？当达娜想要晋升时，她把她想要的变成了一种期望。我想要晋升，她把它变成了我必须晋升。当有人结婚时，他们有一个希望，你知道，我希望我的伴侣忠诚，但他们把它变成了他们必须忠诚。那是对他人行为的一项你实际上没有权力去执行的规则。如果你早上醒来，你说，嘿，我今天有个大日子，必须是晴天，结果却在倾盆大雨，大多数正常人都会意识到
they don't control the weather. But when an adult person does something that you don't want, we bypass that. Well, a normal adult person doesn't have to do what I want. But when we create unenforceable rules, we start thinking an adult separate from me has to do what I want. They have to give me a promotion.
他们无法控制天气。但当一个成年人做了一件你不想让他们做的事时，我们绕过了这一点。嗯，一个正常的成年人不必做我想要的事。但当我们创造不可执行的规则时，我们开始认为一个独立于我的成年人必须做我想要的事。他们必须给我升职。
They have to stay my friend, they have to be faithful, or also they have to talk to me. Those unenforceable rules are rigid like substrates in our thinking that when they're broken, cause us to have all sorts of exaggerated distress. I want to talk about one unenforceable rule that you had in your life, Fred. When your mother-in-law was alive, you and your family would often go and visit her in Connecticut. I understand that she wasn't very nice to you. You could say that.
他们必须做我的朋友，他们必须忠诚，否则他们必须和我说话。这些不可执行的规则就像我们思维中的僵硬基质，当它们被打破时，会导致我们产生各种夸张的痛苦。我想谈谈你生活中曾有过的这样一个不可执行的规则，弗雷德。在你岳母活着的时候，你和你的家人经常去康涅狄格州看望她。我听说她对你不是很友好。你可以这么说。
And let's just say it was a relationship challenge. But yes, there was one situation where she demanded that I do something in her home and it was absolutely trivial. It was something along the lines of, don't put this back here. You have to put it back here. And she was yelling at me because I had put it back in the wrong place. So she had an unenforceable, like, sons-in-law can't put things back where I don't want them put back.
我们就说这是一个关系挑战吧。但是是的，有一种情况下，她要求我在她家里做一件事，而且那绝对是微不足道的小事。那大概是类似这样的话：不要把这个放回这里。你必须把它放回这里。她冲我大喊大叫，因为我把它放错了地方。所以她有一个不可执行的规则，比如，女婿不能把东西放在我不想让他们放的地方。
And then I had an unenforceable, like, moms-in-law can't talk to me like this. I heard myself saying it in my mind you can't talk to me like this and I ran out the front door. I literally ran out the front door ran away from my wife and her family literally took a run because my unenforceable role was shouting at me, she can't do this. How dare she do this? Who is she to do this? I was gone for like an hour. My wife thought I was crazy enough to have gone back to California. She wondered, but, and I'm not blaming one shred of this on my mother-in-law.
然后我有一个不可执行的规则，比如，岳母不能这样跟我说话。我听到自己在心里说，你不能这样跟我说话，然后我夺门而出。我literally 夺门而出，逃离了我的妻子和她的家人，literally 跑了出去，因为我的不可执行规则在对我大喊，她怎么能这样？她怎么敢这样做？她算老几敢这么做？我离开了一个多小时。我妻子甚至以为我疯狂到已经回加利福尼亚了。她很纳闷，但是，我没有把这其中的哪怕一丝一毫归咎于我的岳母。
I'm saying my rule, she broke my rule so strongly that I could only react that way because of the rule, not the reality of what she did. that way because of the rule, not the reality of what she did. So after this fight, I understand that you called a friend to complain about your mother-in-law. You wanted to tell someone else your grievance story. What did you say and what did your friend tell you? So either during that run or later, I went to the payphone. I didn't want to do it in the house, and I called up really close friends,
我是说我的规则，她打破我的规则的力度如此之大，以至于我只能做出那样的反应，这是因为那个规则，而不是她所做事情的现实。是因为那个规则，而不是她所做事情的现实。所以在这次争吵之后，我听说你给一个朋友打电话抱怨你的岳母。你想把你的怨恨故事讲给别人听。你说了什么，你的朋友对你说了什么？所以无论是在跑步期间还是之后，我走到公用电话亭。我不想在房子里打，我打给了非常亲密的朋友，
and I started to complain about my mother-in-law. And I got about 10 seconds in, and the friend said, Fred, every time you go there, you call me to complain. And I looked at myself, and I looked at him and said, but this one's serious. And he said, I'm sure it's serious, but every single time you go there, you call us to complain about her and you want us to agree with you. So complain and we'll agree with you.
我开始抱怨我的岳母。我刚讲了大约10秒钟，那个朋友就说，弗雷德，每次你去那儿，你都打电话给我抱怨。我审视了一下自己，看着他说，但这次是认真的。他说，我确信是认真的，但每次你去那儿，你都打电话给我们抱怨她，并且希望我们同意你的观点。所以尽管抱怨，我们会同意你的。
But understand you do this every time. A light bulb went off. Wow, this woman owns me. She owns my nervous system. She owns my mind. She owns my mind. She owns my feet. They take me to the phone. She owns me. We've talked about the anatomy of grudges and how they form. Let's spend a moment talking about some of the consequences
但你要明白你每次都这样。一个灯泡亮了。哇，这个女人拥有我。她拥有我的神经系统。她拥有我的思维。她拥有我的思维。她拥有我的双脚。它们把我带到电话前。她拥有我。我们已经讨论了怨恨的解剖结构以及它们是如何形成的。让我们花点时间谈谈心怀怨恨的一些后果
of holding on to our past grievances. Many studies have examined the relationship between resentment and mental health issues. One study for example found that holding a grudge could lead to lower self-esteem. I mean there's lots of information about how hostile thoughts, resentment and blame are all negatives for long-term physical well-being. One of the studies that I liked when I was doing a lot of this was there was a linear relationship between blame and all cause like physical well-being. There is a good degree of evidence that hostile people have greater heart disease.
我们对过去怨恨的坚持。许多研究都探讨了怨恨与心理健康问题之间的关系。例如，一项研究发现，心怀怨恨会导致自尊心降低。我的意思是，有很多信息表明，敌意想法、怨恨和责备对长期的身体健康都是负面的。在我做这方面大量研究时，我喜欢的一项研究发现，责备与所有原因导致的身体健康状况之间存在线性关系。有相当多的证据表明，怀有敌意的人患心脏病的风险更高。
I feel like I can remember times in my own life, Fred, when I've been up at 3.45 in the morning, upset about what someone said to me or what someone did to me, and I'm lying in bed tossing and turning, I can't sleep, I'm angry. And of course, it seems like the effects on sleep must be one of the effects of resentment and grievance. Yeah, and there was a recent study that linked the what you're calling perseveration and anger, both were linked to sleep quality.
我觉得我能记住自己生活中的一些时刻，弗雷德，当时我在凌晨3点45分还醒着，为别人对我说的话或做的事感到沮丧，我躺在床上辗转反侧，无法入睡，我很生气。当然，对睡眠的影响必然是怨恨和怨气的后果之一。是的，最近有一项研究将你所称的反复反刍和愤怒联系起来，这两者都与睡眠质量有关。
Why is it that grievance and grudges cause these physiological effects? What is happening physiologically to us that cause an effect on sleep, that cause an effect on the heart, that cause an effect on high blood pressure? Well I mean the clearest and simplest link is with the stress response. So when you're angry or when you're pissed off or when you're blaming, you have an internalized sense of threat. Someone out there has hurt you or disappointed you or left you and you're not okay. So that sense of not okay, you know, leads the brain and it signals to the adrenals and all sorts of changes to prepare you to, you know, run away.
为什么怨恨和记仇会引起这些生理效应呢？在我们身上到底发生了什么生理变化，从而对睡眠产生影响、对心脏产生影响、对高血压产生影响？嗯，我的意思是，最清晰、最简单的联系是与应激反应有关。所以当你生气、恼火或责备时，你有一种内在的威胁感。外面有人伤害了你、让你失望了或抛弃了你，你感觉不好。所以这种感觉不好，你知道，会引导大脑并向肾上腺发出信号，引发各种变化，让你做好准备，你知道，逃跑。
And run away doesn't have to be physically run away. It could be I'll never talk to them again. That's a form of flight or fight them, be hostile. But the more you're angry and the more you're blaming, the more you arouse that system, the more you trigger an adrenalized response, the more you train your body to accommodate cortisol, the more your brain gets used to that pathway of reaction, it develops practice effects. It becomes easier to do because the templates become laid down more succinctly.
而逃跑不一定非得是身体上的逃跑。它可能是“我再也不和他们说话了”。那是逃跑的一种形式，或者是战斗，表现出敌意。但你越生气，越责备，你对那个系统的刺激就越多，你触发的肾上腺素反应就越多，你训练身体适应皮质醇的程度就越高，你的大脑就越习惯于那种反应路径，它就会产生练习效应。这变得更容易做到，因为反应模板被勾勒得更加清晰。
The immediacy of arousal of anything that's a threat to us is the reason why long-term grievances are so dangerous. So the irony here, Fred, is that grudges can make us feel better in the short term. They make us feel like we're getting back at the people who've hurt us. But the people they hurt the most might be us. There's a distinction made between constructive and destructive anger. So when our arousal and our physiology and our threats say we need to protect ourselves, anger can be a really good response.
任何对我们构成威胁的事物被唤醒的即时性，就是长期怨恨如此危险的原因。所以这里的讽刺之处在于，弗雷德，怨恨可以让我们在短期内感觉好一些。它们让我们觉得我们在报复那些伤害我们的人。但它们伤害最深的人可能正是我们自己。建设性愤怒和破坏性愤怒之间存在区别。因此，当我们的唤醒、我们的生理状态和我们的威胁感表明我们需要保护自己时，愤怒可以是一种非常好的反应。
So if somebody is hurting your kid, get angry. It's really helpful. If you see an injustice, get angry. Notice it and recognize you want this to change. The destructive anger is when anger does not lead to useful action. When it just becomes perseverative and in a grievance, it actually becomes a substitute for action. In a chronic anger situation, there's a little bit of dopamine that you get, that pleasure chemical, ah, I'm doing something about it. When actually you're doing nothing constructive about it. The dopamine is a response to an anticipated value, but in anger you never get that anticipated value
所以如果有人在伤害你的孩子，生气吧。这真的很有帮助。如果你看到不公正，生气吧。注意到它并认识到你希望改变这种情况。破坏性的愤怒是当愤怒没有转化为有用的行动时。当它只是变成反复反刍和怨恨时，它实际上成了行动的替代品。在长期的愤怒状态下，你会得到一点多巴胺，那种快乐的化学物质，“啊，我正在为此采取行动”。而实际上你并没有采取任何建设性的行动。多巴胺是对预期价值的反应，但在愤怒中，你永远无法得到那个预期价值，
unless you actually do something and change. When we come back, strategies for letting go of the past. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In the late 1960s, tensions were exploding in Northern Ireland. Riots were breaking out in cities like Belfast and Derry. People were sharply divided on whether to remain part of the United Kingdom or to join the Republic of Ireland. Catholic nationalists wanted unity with Ireland and Protestant Unionists wanted the country to stay within the United Kingdom. Decades of
除非你真的采取行动并做出改变。稍后回来，我们将探讨放下过去的策略。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在20世纪60年代后期，北爱尔兰的紧张局势正在爆发。贝尔法斯特和德里等城市爆发了骚乱。人们对于是继续留在联合王国境内还是加入爱尔兰共和国存在巨大分歧。天主教民族主义者想要与爱尔兰统一，而新教联合主义者则希望国家留在联合王国境内。数十年的
hostility and turmoil led to what became known as the Troubles, a violent conflict that involved bombings, shootings, and the killing of many people. More than 3,500 people were killed in the conflict, the majority of them civilians. Many people were left grieving over horrific losses. In another part of the world at the time, Fred Luskin was at Stanford University in California studying the role of forgiveness in people's lives. A man named Byron Bland reached out to Fred after reading newspaper articles about his work at Stanford. Byron asked, was Fred willing to try his forgiveness training with mothers who had lost their children
敌意和动荡导致了后来被称为“动乱”的时期，这是一场涉及爆炸、枪击和杀害许多人的暴力冲突。冲突中共有3500多人丧生，其中大多数是平民。许多人因可怕的损失而陷入悲伤。而在当时世界上的另一个地方，弗雷德·卢斯金正在加利福尼亚的斯坦福大学研究宽恕在人们生活中的作用。一个名叫拜伦·布兰德的人在读到关于他在斯坦福工作的报纸文章后，联系了弗雷德。拜伦问，弗雷德是否愿意尝试对那些在动乱中失去了孩子的母亲们进行宽恕培训？
to the troubles? Their stories were unimaginably painful. One woman's son had been kidnapped on the way to work, then ushered into a shallow grave where he was shot, his body hidden for 21 years. Another woman's son had been working at a restaurant when a gunman walked up to the takeout window and shot him seven times.
她们的故事痛苦得令人难以想象。一位女士的儿子在上班途中被绑架，然后被带到一个浅浅的坟墓前枪杀，尸体被隐藏了21年。另一位女士的儿子在一家餐馆工作时，一名枪手走到外卖窗口向他连开七枪。
He died on the spot. A third woman said her Protestant son was hanging out with his Catholic friend at a pub when a loyalist rushed in and shot both men dead. The stories went on. When the women were flown to California to share their stories, Fred found himself overwhelmed with horror.
他当场身亡。第三位女士说，她的新教徒儿子正和他的天主教朋友在一家酒吧闲逛时，一名忠诚派冲进来将两人枪杀。这样的故事还在继续。当这些女性被接到加利福尼亚分享她们的故事时，弗雷德感到被极度的惊恐所淹没。
But he listened and he began the training. It overwhelmed with horror. But he listened, and he began the training. It started with intake. He asked them to fill out questionnaires about their mental state. Then, slowly and carefully, he took them through the steps he had developed. One was along the lines of his own epiphany at Safeway. When you are deeply upset about something, take a moment to notice things you are not upset about. So one time we brought them to the window of the fifth floor of the building.
但他倾听了，并开始了培训。感到被极度的惊恐所淹没。但他倾听了，并开始了培训。培训从接待开始。他让她们填写关于她们精神状态的问卷。然后，缓慢而小心地，他带她们经历了他开发的一些步骤。其中一个类似于他在Safeway的顿悟。当你对某事感到深深的沮丧时，花点时间注意那些你没有感到沮丧的事情。所以有一次我们把她们带到了大楼五楼的窗户前。
On Stanford's campus, we opened the blinds and said, literally, let the sun in, that this murder is a horror, but it's in your past, and you want to make sure that this murder doesn't serve as like a full solar eclipse, and it doesn't mean that this didn't happen, but you can open back up to goodness. goodness, and we gave them some practice in changing the story that they tell, the grievance story, not just to talk about how terrible it was, but what are some possibilities for moving forward. I'm wondering whether you heard from these women or you hear from other people you work with, Fred, a sense of anger directed toward you because these are people who are saying, I've been through something terrible
在斯坦福的校园里，我们拉开百叶窗说，字面意思，让阳光进来，这场谋杀是一场悲剧，但它已经成为你的过去，你想要确保这场谋杀不会像一次完整的日食那样，这并不意味着这件事没有发生，但你可以重新向美好开放。美好，并且我们让她们进行了一些练习，练习改变她们讲述的故事，即怨恨的故事，不仅是谈论它有多么可怕，还有哪些前行的可能。我在想，弗雷德，你是否听到过这些女性或你合作过其他人对你产生愤怒的情绪，因为这些人会说，我经历过可怕的事情，
and the person who did this terrible thing to me, really it's unforgivable. And here's Fred Luskin coming in and telling me to forgive and forget. I mean, do you get people angry with you because in some ways it can feel, even though that's not what you're doing, but it can feel like you're taking the side of the transgressor. I never tell people to forgive and forget. I tell to them that forgiveness is not condoning, it's saving
而对做这件可怕事情的人，真的，这是不可原谅的。而弗雷德·卢斯金却跑来告诉我要原谅和忘记。我的意思是，人们会生你的气吗？因为在某种程度上，尽管这不是你的本意，但这可能会让人觉得你站在了违法者的一边。我从不告诉人们去原谅和忘记。我告诉他们的是，宽恕不是纵容，而是拯救
your life. I remind them that forgiveness has nothing to do with seeking justice. Forgiveness is inner healing and making peace with the life you had, not endlessly arguing with what you didn't get. The other thing is the whole orientation is a profound empathy There is a profound empathy for how much someone has suffered and a plea for them to not continue parts of this suffering that are under your control by fighting hard against what actually happened. So there's an empathic plea. They stole so much from you. Don't let them steal more.
你的生命。我提醒他们，宽恕与寻求正义无关。宽恕是内心疗愈，是与你所拥有的生活讲和，而不是无休止地与你没有得到的东西争论。另一件事是整个导向是深刻的同情。对某人遭受了多少苦难有着深刻的同情，并恳求他们不要通过极力对抗实际发生的事情，来继续那些在他们控制之下的苦难部分。所以这是一个充满同情的恳求。他们从你身上夺走了那么多。不要让他们夺走更多。
What was the effect of these ideas on the women who went through the program, Fred? It was mixed. They themselves, on the whole, reported improvement in mood and a dimming of the symptoms of stress. When they went back to Northern Ireland, it became much more dicey because their communities didn't want to hear about forgiveness. They themselves didn't give me grief, but their communities were not interested in going to fancy California and learning to do this. So that was one obstacle that we learned about. The most satisfying moment of this in a very difficult experience was the second time we
这些想法对经历过该项目的女性产生了什么影响，弗雷德？效果是复杂的。总体而言，她们自己报告说情绪有所改善，压力症状有所减弱。当她们回到北爱尔兰时，情况变得更加棘手，因为她们的社区不想听到关于宽恕的事情。她们自己没有给我带来麻烦，但她们的社区对去花哨的加利福尼亚学习做这件事不感兴趣。所以这是我们了解到的一大障碍。在这个非常困难的经历中，最令人满意的时刻是我们第二次把
brought these women back plus family members, not all of them. And one of the women's daughters, a middle-aged woman, came to us and said, thank you for giving us our mother back. She was just grief-stricken. And, you know, we couldn't get through to her. And you reminded her you can be grief-stricken and still in the present, try to love and hold what's still good in your life. It's interesting, you know, the word forgiveness itself I think points our
这些女性连同她们的家人接回来，虽然不是所有人。其中一位女性的女儿，一位中年女性，来到我们面前说：“谢谢你们把我们的母亲还给我们。”她当时悲痛欲绝。而且，你知道，我们无法走近她。而你提醒了她，你可以悲痛欲绝，但仍然可以活在当下，去尝试爱并守护你生活中依然美好的东西。有趣的是，你知道，宽恕这个词本身，我认为将我们的
mind toward the person who has done us harm, the person who has done us wrong. You know, when I think I forgive you, I'm thinking that my forgiveness is directed toward you. But everything that I'm hearing from you, Fred, it's that really forgiveness, in fact, is not about the other person at all. It's about ourselves. It can be for the other person in an important intimate relationship. in an important intimate relationship. So if your partner cheats, you can forgive both to free you and them. But it's an unenforceable rule thinking that if I forgive them, like they're going to change or they forgive me, we don't have control over the other. Part of the problem of unforgiveness is our lack of control of what happened makes us feel so vulnerable and threatened that if we don't come up with a strategy that puts some of the control back in our hands,
心思引向了那个对我们造成伤害的人，那个对我们做错事的人。你知道，当我脑海中浮现“我原谅你”时，我认为我的原谅是针对你的。但我从你这里听到的一切，弗雷德，实际上宽恕根本与另一个人无关。它关乎我们自己。在一个重要的亲密关系中，它确实可以为了另一个人。在一个重要的亲密关系中。所以如果你的伴侣出轨了，你可以选择原谅，既为了解放你，也为了解放他们。但如果认为“如果我原谅他们，他们就会改变”或者“他们原谅我”，这就是不可执行的规则思维，我们无法控制他人。不宽恕的部分问题在于我们对发生的事情缺乏控制，这让我们感到如此脆弱和受到威胁，如果我们不提出一种把一些控制权交回我们手中的策略，
we can feel lost and scared for a long time. The simplest example is an intimate partnership. If your partner is a schnook and cheats on you and you don't let that go, then you sometimes bring that to the next relationship. You're going to cheat on me. I can't trust you. If you forgive it, it's not necessarily to help the past partner, but you open back up to a kind of trust so the next partner doesn't have to deal with your woundedness. We talked earlier about your mother-in-law and how she would often make rude and critical
我们可能会感到迷失和害怕很长一段时间。最简单的例子就是亲密关系。如果你的伴侣是个混蛋并且出轨了，而你没有放手，那么你有时会把这种情绪带到下一段关系中。“你会背叛我。我不能信任你。”如果你原谅了，并不一定是为了帮助过去的那位伴侣，而是你重新对一种信任敞开心扉，这样下一个伴侣就不必面对你那受伤的心态了。我们之前讨论过你的岳母以及她如何经常表现出粗鲁和批判。
comments about you. And some of this might have been because she was, you know, you could say an exceptionally tidy person or you could say an obsessively tidy person, depending on your point of view. But at one point you asked yourself a question with her that also made a very big difference in the way you responded to her. What was this question, Fred? When I got off the phone with those friends and I had already started the forgiveness project, but it wasn't finished.
关于你的评论。其中一部分原因可能是她，你知道的，你可以说是一个极其爱整洁的人，或者从不同的角度来看，也可以说是一个对整洁有强迫倾向的人。但在某个时刻，你针对她问了自己一个问题，这也极大地改变了你对她的反应。弗雷德，这是个什么问题？当我挂断那些朋友的电话时，我已经开始了宽恕计划，但它还没有完成。
I realized I need a new story. I can't keep on telling everybody how terrible my mother-in-law is and how helpless I am. I came up with a new story, which is I asked myself, Fred, why are you here? Why are you visiting her? And I said, because I want to support my partner, my wife, and I want my kids to know their grandma. So I said, why don't you act like it? You show up and you're a bear.
我意识到我需要一个新的故事。我不能再到处跟人诉说我婆婆有多糟糕，我自己有多无奈。我想出了一个新故事，那就是我问自己：弗雷德，你为什么在这里？你为什么要去看望她？我说，因为我想支持我的伴侣、我的妻子，我也想让我的孩子们了解他们的奶奶。所以我说：你为什么不表现得像个支持者呢？你一出现就像个暴躁的家伙。
You're not helping your wife. You're not helping your kids. If you can't do it, don't go. I wasn't there to get along with my mother-in-law. I was there to really support my wife. It changed my behavior 180 degrees, changed me inside, and it transformed the Forgiveness Project into something really useful. Positive intention. What do you want? Why are you there? What positive thing can you move forward on so that the grievance is in the rear-view mirror and not out your front windshield? I understand that at one point toward the end of her life, your mother-in-law had a
你没有在帮你的妻子。你没有在帮你的孩子们。如果你做不到，那就别去。我去那里不是为了和婆婆搞好关系的。我是为了真正支持我的妻子。这让我的行为发生了180度的转变，改变了我的内心，并将宽恕计划变成了一个真正有用的东西。积极的意图。你想要什么？你为什么在那？你能推动什么积极的事情向前发展，让怨恨留在后视镜里，而不是留在前挡风玻璃外面？我了解到，在她生命的末期，你的婆婆曾有一次
chat with you about the way she may have treated you. Tell me about that story and what happened, Fred. That was one of the most poignant experiences of my life. When my wife died, which is now about 13 years ago, I continued to visit her parents. And I showed up at their home and I knocked at the door and she comes out. I mean, we had made a peace together, but we hadn't like healed.
跟你聊过她过去对待你的方式。弗雷德，跟我讲讲那个故事以及发生了什么。那是我一生中最辛酸的经历之一。我妻子去世大约已经13年了，我继续去看望她的父母。我来到他们家门前，敲了敲门，她出来了。我的意思是，我们已经言归于好了，但我们还没有真正疗愈。
And this was a woman who was suffering from some dementia. And she comes out and she looks at me and says, I don't think I was that nice to you sometimes, was I? And this was a woman who was suffering from some dementia. And I said, no, at times you really weren't. And she said, I'm sorry. And I said, of course, fully accepted. The piece that completely ends this is, I went back home, thought about that, and here I am, a big shot forgiveness teacher,
而这是一个患有某种痴呆症的女人。她走出来，看着我说：“有时候我对你好像不是很好，对吧？”而这是一个患有某种痴呆症的女人。我说：“不，有时候确实不太好。”她说：“对不起。”我说：“当然，完全接受。”让这件事彻底画上句号的是，我回家后想了想，而我呢，可是一位大名鼎鼎的宽恕导师，
and an older woman makes the first step. That doesn't look good. And the next time I went and visited them, I knocked on her door and I said, remember when you told me that you were sorry for treating me a certain way? I said, well, I'm here to apologize to you. I'm sorry for all the ways that I may not have been a good son-in-law and just made your life harder. I'm deeply sorry for that. And I think we both hurt your daughter.
却让一个老年妇女迈出了第一步。这可不太好看。下次我去拜访他们时，我敲了敲她的门，我说：“还记得你对我说过，你为自己过去那种方式对待我感到抱歉吗？我说，嗯，我是来向你道歉的。我为自己可能没有做好一个女婿、让你们的生活变得更加艰难的种种行为道歉。我对此深表歉意。而且我想我们两个人都伤害了你的女儿。”
So please accept my apology. She smiled a little, she was, you know, not fully there. Forgiveness wrapped it up in a bow, we're both clean, and it's as if it never happened. When we come back, Fred offers more techniques to get us moving when we find ourselves stuck on a grudge. Plus, we take a look at some of the physiological benefits of forgiveness. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
“所以请接受我的道歉。”她微微一笑，你知道的，当时她的意识已经不太清醒了。宽恕把这一切完美地包裹起来，我们两个人都释怀了，就好像事情从未发生过一样。当我们回来时，弗雷德将提供更多技巧，帮助我们在发现自己陷入怨恨时能够动起来。此外，我们还将探讨宽恕的一些生理益处。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Many of us want to be rid of our grudges, but we find that the grievance keeps rearing its head. Pay attention to me, it tells us. Forgiveness is for suckers. We find ourselves drawn irresistibly to rehashing the events that caused us pain. We may go back to complaining to others about how we have been wronged. Fred Luskin sometimes tells the people he is trying to help about a psychological experiment. It was a piece of research where they experimented with giving people scenarios and asking them to assume the role of different people in scenarios. So one of the scenarios that I remember was a bicycle accident where a car was driving
我们许多人都想摆却脱心中的怨恨，但我们发现这种委屈总是不断抬头。它对我们说：“关注我吧。”“宽恕是给傻瓜准备的。”我们发现自己不可抗拒地被吸引去重温那些给我们带来痛苦的事件。我们可能会不断向他人抱怨自己是如何受到不公正对待的。弗雷德·拉斯金有时会向他试图帮助的人讲述一个心理学实验。这是一项研究，他们通过给人们提供不同的情景，让他们在情景中扮演不同角色的实验。我记得其中一个情景是一起自行车事故，一辆汽车在行驶时
and it hit a bicycle. It was not a terrible accident, nobody was killed, but they asked people to assume the role of car driver. So in their stories, the bike drivers weaving all over the place and they're honking their horn and slowing down and skillfully trying to get around them. When they're in the role of bicyclists, it's this lunatic speeding driver came up behind me without any warning and scared the crap out of me.
撞上了一辆自行车。这不是一场可怕的事故，没有人丧生，但他们要求人们扮演汽车司机的角色。所以在他们的故事里，骑自行车的人在路上东倒西歪，而他们在按喇叭、减速，并且熟练地试图绕过对方。当他们处于骑自行车的人的角色时，故事就成了：这个疯狂的超速司机毫无预兆地从我身后冲过来，吓得我魂飞魄散。
I know from the show you do that you know about the negativity bias, the profound effect of our brain of finding things wrong and looking for problems. And I know because of the work you do that you know about the confirmation bias, you know, our meaning-making apparatus are so biased, but they are biased mostly in the direction of threat. they are biased mostly in the direction of threat. Since threat, that negativity bias is there to protect us, so many of the responses that we consider innate are actually off kilter because of our need and desperate biological necessity
从你做的节目中我了解到，你对 negativity bias（负面偏见）有所耳闻，即我们的大脑在发现错误和寻找问题方面具有深远的影响。而且由于你所做的工作，我知道你对 confirmation bias（确认偏误）有所了解，你知道，我们的大脑赋予意义的机制是如此具有倾向性，但它们主要倾向于威胁的方向。因为威胁，这种负面偏见的存在是为了保护我们，所以我们认为许多天生的反应实际上都是扭曲的，这是因为我们有需求和迫切的生物学必要性
to deal with danger and threat. So in an accident, you're gonna distort this to keep your ego intact to deal with the threat. Fred and other researchers have also found that once we are down the path of constructing a grievance story, our minds reach for more and more evidence that our state of mind is justified. Our memories are state dependent so that when you're unhappy that gives greater access in your brain to other times when you were unhappy.
来应对危险和威胁。所以在事故中，你会扭曲这一点来保持你的自我完整，以应对威胁。弗雷德和其他研究人员还发现，一旦我们沿着构建委屈故事的道路走下去，我们的思想就会寻找越来越多的证据，来证明我们的这种心态是正当的。我们的记忆具有状态依赖性，因此当你感到不高兴时，它会让你更容易在大脑中调出你过去其他不快乐的时刻。
When you're angry, you have greater access to stories and times when you were angry. That is to allow us to draw upon the past as to how to solve the issue that we're dealing with now. So it would do no good if you're angry now and your memory is accessed to lying on the beach in Hawaii. You're not going to get much information. So when we have a habit of creating grievin stories around life. Not only are we reacting to the current experience, but we get access to a pattern of creating grievin stories that makes the current story seem more real and the response to it seem more usual.
当你生气时，你就能更容易地调出那些让你生气的记忆和故事。这是为了让我们能够借鉴过去，来解决我们当前正在处理的问题。因此，如果你现在很生气，而你的记忆调出的是躺在夏威夷的海滩上，那是没有任何帮助的。你不会获得太多信息。因此，当我们习惯于围绕生活创造委屈的故事时，我们不仅在对当前的经历做出反应，而且我们还获得了一种创造委屈故事的模式，这使得当前的故事看起来更加真实，对其的反应也显得更加正常。
Hmm, you know, I'm thinking back to the moment you went to the grocery store, you know against your wishes to get something your wife wanted and of course you're thinking about your friend Sam and you're thinking about the way in which he had hurt your feelings and the way in which you know it was unfair that he treated you the way he treated you. And then you show up at the grocery store and now the thing that you wanted is not in the grocery store. Now that's yet another piece of evidence that the universe in fact is unfair against you,
嗯，你知道的，我回想起你违背意愿去杂货店买你妻子想要的东西的那一刻，当然你会想起你的朋友山姆，你会想起他伤害你感情的方式，以及他那样对待你是多么不公平的方式。然后你出现在杂货店里，现在你想要的东西在杂货店里没有了。现在这又是宇宙事实上对你不公的又一个证据，
Fred, and you can see how these different stories now are circling around one another and forming a braid. And it allowed me to tell my wife that she was unfair sending me to the supermarket that I didn't want to go to. One technique that you teach is to ask people to be mindful about the interventions they have tried in the past and the effectiveness of those interventions. You worked with a woman named Alice who did not get along with her in-laws. Tell me how she tried to fix the problem and how you helped her. I mean, Alice, like everybody, tries usually what the fight or flight brain gives it. So if you don't like your in-laws, you go, well, I'm not going to talk to them, or I
弗雷德，你可以看到这些不同的故事现在是如何相互盘旋并交织成一条辫子的。这让我得以对妻子说，她派我去我不想去的超市是不公平的。你教导的一个技巧是要求人们对他们过去尝试过的干预措施及其有效性保持正念。你曾与一位名叫爱丽丝的女士合作，她和婆家相处得不好。跟我讲讲她是如何试图解决这个问题的，以及你是如何帮助她的。我的意思是，爱丽丝和所有人一样，通常会尝试战斗或逃离的大脑所给出的本能反应。所以如果你不喜欢你的亲家，你就会想，好吧，我不跟他们说话，或者我
am going to tell them how I feel, or I'm going to stew, or I'm going to tell my husband to stop. Or sometimes you say, well, none of that worked, so I won't talk to them, or I'll make the conversation short, or when they visit, I won't talk to them or I'll make the conversation short or when they visit I won't be here and the really handy thing is instead of continuing Strategies that don't help you
要告诉他们我的感受，或者我要生闷气，或者我要叫我丈夫去制止。或者有时你会说，好吧，那些都没用，所以我不会跟他们说话，或者我会把谈话缩短，或者当他们来访时，我不会跟他们说话，或者我会把谈话缩短，或者当他们来访时，我不会在这里。而真正简便的做法是，与其继续使用那些对你没有帮助的策略，
Take 15 minutes and write them down So we asked Alice. What do you do when you in-laws are not what you want them to be? She wrote down six things. We said, did they work? She said, no. We said, don't do them again. And so we saved Alice a lot of grief because if like being snarky to your in-laws is not helpful, at least don't be snarky. Say to yourself, I know what doesn't work, let me see if I can
不如花15分钟把它写下来。所以我们问爱丽丝：“当你的亲家表现不如你意时，你会怎么做？”她写下了六件事。我们问：“它们管用吗？”她说：“没有。”我们说：“那就别再做了。”因此我们为爱丽丝省去了许多痛苦，因为如果对亲家冷嘲热讽是没有帮助的，至少不要去冷嘲热讽。对自己说：“我知道什么不管用，让我看看我能不能
experiment to find out what does work. And of course the point that you're making here is that very often when we're carrying grievances around, we try the same thing over and over and over and over again. We come back to the same strategy over and over again. It doesn't work, but we say, okay, next time I'm really gonna tell this person off and next time they're gonna come to their senses and realize how much they've wronged me. But that's the direct result of anger on the brain. Anger reduces blood flow to the prefrontal cortex. Your thinking capacities and your creativity are dimmed. If you can
通过实验找出什么管用。”当然，你这里要指出的重点是，很多时候当我们怀揣委屈时，我们会一遍又一遍、反反复复地尝试同一件事情。我们一遍又一遍地回到相同的策略。它不管用，但我们却说：“好吧，下次我一定要狠狠地数落这个人，下次他们就会清醒过来，意识到他们对我有多么不公。”但这正是大脑受到愤怒影响的直接结果。愤怒会减少流向前额叶皮层的血流量。你的思考能力和创造力都会减弱。如果你能在
soothe that anger in the moment, then you get your blood flow and your brain back and you get a chance to think of some different strategies and that is the simplest description of how forgiveness is helpful. Fred walked me through a mental practice he calls positive emotion refocusing technique or PIRT for short. Just take two slow deep breaths into and out of your belly. Slow and deep. Just take two slow deep breaths into and out of your belly. And when your belly inhales, allow it to expand.
当下平息那种愤怒，那么你的血流量和大脑就会恢复，你就有机会想出一些不同的策略，这就是对宽恕如何发挥作用的最简单描述。弗雷德带我进行了一种他称之为“积极情感重新聚焦技术”（简称 PIRT）的精神练习。只需对着你的腹部缓慢而深沉地做两次深呼吸。缓慢而深沉。只需对着你的腹部缓慢而深沉地做两次深呼吸。当你的腹部吸气时，让它扩张开来。
And now bring to your mind's eye a picture of someone you love. Just bring to your mind's eye a picture of someone you really, really, really love. And try to feel that love in your body. Try to almost feel it open your eyes. What we taught Alice and all the women from Northern Ireland is, when you get a picture or a thought about your mother-in-law or the murder, practice this. Don't allow your nervous system to be hijacked by stress.
现在，在你的脑海中浮现出你爱的人的照片。只需在脑海中浮现出你真正、真正、真正爱的人的照片。并试着在你的身体里感受这种爱。试着去感受它仿佛睁开了你的眼睛。我们教给爱丽丝和所有北爱尔兰女性的是：当你脑海中出现关于你婆婆或凶杀案的画面或想法时，练习这个。不要让你的神经系统被压力劫持。
Practice this immediately. We told the women in Northern Ireland, you may have to practice this 50 times before it has an impact, but then you're starting to counter condition your stress response. With Alice, it wasn't quite that tough, you know, it was so maybe after eight practices we'd say, okay, you got your mind back, we'd say, okay, you got your mind back. Now what can you do? What might be a strategy to use with either your husband or your in-laws that doesn't bring back stress for you? And that becomes the inner guidepost. So she said, well, I guess I could just take a deep breath when they upset me. And I'd say, beautiful, try that.
立即练习这个。我们告诉北爱尔兰的女性：你可能需要练习50次它才会产生影响，但随后你就在开始反向调节你的压力反应。对爱丽丝来说，情况没那么艰难，你知道的，也许在练习了8次之后我们会说：“好吧，你找回理智了，我们说，好吧，你找回理智了。现在你能做什么？有什么策略可以用来对待你的丈夫或亲家，而又不会给你带来压力呢？”这就成了內心的路标。所以她说：“嗯，我想当他们惹恼我时，我只需要深吸一口气就行了。”我会说：“太棒了，试试看。”
Or instead of giving your husband grief, ask for his help. You can't come up with any of those solutions as long as fight or flight is active. So PERT is just a simple practice to shut that down. The Old Saying Fred says there is lots of evidence that reducing hostility is good for our mental and physical health. The old saying is true. Anger does the most harm to the vessel that stores it. One analysis found that far from soothing our pain,
或者与其给你的丈夫添堵，不如向他寻求帮助。只要战斗或逃跑机制处于活跃状态，你就无法想出任何这些解决方案。所以 PIRT 只是一个用来关闭该机制的简单练习。古老的谚语。弗雷德说，有大量证据表明，减少敌意对我们的身心健康都有好处。那句老话说得对。愤怒对储存它的容器造成的伤害最大。一项分析发现，这些怨恨非但不能平息我们的痛苦，
grudges have a way of increasing our experience of chronic suffering as seen in conditions like fibromyalgia. It's a study that reviewed all the research and suggested pathways for how forgiveness could reduce the rumination and anger that are so constant companions to fibromyalgia. And they now know that the pain pathways of the physical parts and amplifies it. So when you reduce your anger and rumination, you reduce the experience of pain. When anger becomes chronic, that appears to amplify those pain pathways. When anger is soothed, that piece of it can go away from the pain pathway. You also conducted a study that looked at the effects of forgiveness on workplace productivity and well-being. Tell me about that, Fred. Well, we taught people about positive emotional intelligence centered on forgiveness. We took about a hundred people in different work sites and we led them through this
反而会加剧我们经历慢性痛苦的体验，正如在纤维肌痛等病症中所看到的那样。这是一项审查了所有研究并提出了宽恕如何减少反刍和愤怒（它们是纤维肌痛的常见伴侣）的途径的研究。他们现在知道，身体部位的疼痛通路会将其放大。因此，当你减少愤怒和反刍时，你也就减少了疼痛的体验。当愤怒变成慢性时，似乎会放大那些疼痛通路。当愤怒得到平息时，疼痛通路中的那一小部分就可以消失。你还进行了一项研究，考察了宽恕对工作场所生产力和幸福感的影响。弗雷德，跟我讲讲那个以宽恕为中心的积极情商。我们在不同的工作场所挑选了大约一百人，并引导他们完成了这个
process of a little bit of coaching and a workshop and stuff like that. And then we evaluated the end of like six months and it led people to be less stressed, less angry, you know, fewer symptoms of stress, but it also helped be more productive at work. That was the the piece. Now this is an uncontrolled study. We really didn't have a great control group, and it's one group, but it's the kind of study that suggests there might be more here than we acknowledge. We talked earlier about unenforceable rules, the rules we want others to follow, but we cannot make them follow. Let's return to the story of you and your best friend Sam. So you emailed him at the height of your grudge
包含一点点辅导和研讨会之类的小过程。然后在像六个月结束时进行了评估，这让人类压力更小、更不生气，你知道的，压力症状更少了，但它也帮助人们在工作中更有生产力。这就是关键所在。现在这是一项不受控制的研究。我们真的没有一个很好的对照组，而且它只有一个群体，但它是那种表明这里可能比我们承认的更多的研究。我们早些时候讨论过不可执行的规则，即我们希望别人遵守但我们无法强迫他们遵守的规则。让我们回到你和你最好的朋友山姆的故事。所以你在怨恨的顶峰给他发了电子邮件
and told him how you felt. What did you say and how did he respond, Fred? I wrote a blame letter about that. You know, here's all the things you did to ruin my life, so to speak. And it didn't give me what I want, but he wrote me back something that in retrospect wasn't as bad as I received it as, but because I had practiced arousal so much, I'm reading his letter and my blood pressure is like 200 over 120 and my mind's going ballistic and I have all these thoughts of anger and revenge and this was the third learning point for me. I said to myself nobody will ever get this control over my nervous system again long term. So I took a deep breath and I stepped away. I pushed the letter away. I took a deep breath and I pushed myself
并告诉他你的感受。你说了什么，他是怎么回应的，弗雷德？我当时写了一封指责信。你知道的，这里列出了你为了毁掉我的人生而做的所有事情，可以这么说。它并没有给我想要的东西，但他回信给我的内容，事后看来并没有我当时接受的那么糟糕，但因为我之前练习过太多的情绪唤醒，我在读他的信时，我的血压大概是200对120，我的大脑简直要爆炸了，我满脑子都是愤怒和复仇的想法，这是给我的第三个学习点。我对自己说：再也没有人能长期这样控制我的神经系统了。所以我深吸了一口气，退开了。我把信推开。我深吸了一口气，把自己推开
away and I said calm down, calm down. Then I started reading a bit and came up with Pert, but his letter triggered every response that I had practiced for the last six months or a year. He fit right in with a stream going full. I had an unenforceable rule. He has to respond the way I want I had an unenforceable rule He has to be my friend as long as I want him to be my friend I have an unenforceable rule he can't take time off from the relationship. I Then started to untangle those unenforceable rules How did that change your relationship with Sam? Well, after that blame letter, we didn't have contact.
并说：冷静下来，冷静下来。然后我开始读了一点，想出了 PIRT，但他的信触发了我过去六个月或一年里练习过的每一个反应。他正好契合了那条汹涌流淌的河流。我有一个不可执行的规则：他必须按照我想要的方式回应。我有一个不可执行的规则：只要我想让他做我的朋友，他就必须做我的朋友。我有一个不可执行的规则：他不能从这段关系中抽身。我随后开始理清这些不可执行的规则。这如何改变了你和山姆的关系？嗯，在那封指责信之后，我们没有了联系。
But I worked on myself. This is how I developed the forgiveness project. I started trying out my new story with my wife. I created a story that looked forward, not backward. And I got hope again. And then I don't remember who contacted who, but we met for dinner. And I showed up in front of him.
但我开始自我改进。这就是我发展出宽恕计划的过程。我开始在妻子身上尝试我的新故事。我创造了一个向前看而不是向后看的故事。我又重新燃起了希望。然后我不记得是谁联系了谁，我们约了共进晚餐。我出现在他面前。
And I sat down, and I realized that I had forgiven him. And I sat down and I realized that I had forgiven him. But I also realized that all the work I had done for myself, I recognized that I was half the problem. That had I known how to handle this, it never would have escalated the way it did. So inside of myself, I said, I forgive you. I didn't say anything to him. Within about a half an hour, we were the best of friends again, and nothing, there's not even been a blip in decades.
我坐下来，意识到我已经原谅了他。我坐下来，意识到我已经原谅了他。但我也意识到，为了我自己所做的所有工作，我承认我占了问题的一半。如果我当时知道如何处理这件事，它绝不会像后来那样升级。所以在内心深处，我对说：我原谅你。我没有对他说任何话。在大约半小时内，我们又成了最好的朋友，几十年来连一丝波澜都没有过。
Fred Luskin is a psychologist and director of the Stanford University Forgiveness Project. He is the author of Forgive for Good, a proven prescription for health and happiness, and Forgive for Love, the missing ingredient for a healthy and lasting relationship. Fred Luskin, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Hey, this was a delight. Again, thank you for helping me publicize forgiveness. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media.
弗雷德·拉斯金是一位心理学家，也是斯坦福大学宽恕计划的主任。他是《为了美好的宽恕》（Forgive for Good，一本经证明能带来健康和幸福的处方书）以及《为了爱的宽恕》（Forgive for Love，健康持久关系的缺失要素）的作者。弗雷德·拉斯金，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。嘿，这太令人高兴了。再次感谢你帮我宣传宽恕理念。《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。
Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. Do you have follow-up questions about grudges and forgiveness for Fred Luskin? If you'd be comfortable sharing your question with a Hidden Brain audience, please record a voice memo on your phone and email it to us at ideas at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line grudge. That email address again is ideas at hiddenbrain.org. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保罗、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。你对弗雷德·拉斯金关于怨恨和宽恕有什么后续问题吗？如果你愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享你的问题，请在手机上录制一条语音备忘录，并通过电子邮件发送给我们：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。请使用主题行：怨恨。该电子邮件地址再次是 ideas@hiddenbrain.org。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们回头见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。